I'm scary science scary science scary
sights it's a science obscure firstly
let's talk about having our memories are
raised shall we the way I like to think
about what a person is is that
irrespective of my physical body I am
basically a string of memories woven
together into a narrative called Charlie
McDonnell so to me the science fictiony
idea of removing memories is extremely
scary because it's not just like you're
getting rid of some bad experiences but
you're fundamentally changing a person
and who they are but as it happens the
idea of removing memories isn't one just
reserved for films and TV there is
genuinely a drug that exists in the
world that removes memories for real
it's just that so far they've only been
able to remove very very simple memories
from inside the brains of rats but this
memory removal drug that I couldn't find
the name of on the internet has been
trialed in humans and it does work to a
lesser extent instead of removing
memories that just sort of erodes them
so it could actually be possible that if
this science progresses we might one day
see real-life Eternal Sunshine of the
Spotless Mind memory removal clinics
what I think is the really scary thing
about these tests though is what was
actually discovered about how memories
work when they were being done a lot of
people think of the human mind as being
sort of like a hard drive where you can
flick through memories as you like and
those memories are just the same as they
were when they were first created but
turns out that's not actually the case
the scary truth is that every single
time you remember something what you're
actually doing is completely recreating
that memory from scratch and this isn't
a perfect process so every single time
you remember something that memory gets
changed a little bit so what this means
is that the memories you recall the most
often are the ones that are actually
farthest away from what probably
actually happened and that the safest
memories exist inside the minds of
people that can't remember them if the
variability of our silly little human
brains isn't scary enough for you though
secondly I'd like to talk about dangers
in space we're in a pretty good place
here in the universe you know we've got
a nice atmosphere the sun's a good
distance away from us life prospers
everything's dandy apart from the
obvious fact that we're in danger all
the time science is constantly
discovering lots of lovely things out in
the universe and have the potential to
kill us
for example our Sun you might think it's
quite nice gives
life and all that but turns out one day
it's gonna burn us all to death
eventually our Sun is going to run out
of fuel
at which point it will expand to a size
so big that it could potentially engulf
the entire planet Earth but even if it
doesn't it's still going to be about two
thousand times hotter than it currently
is which is hot enough to boil all of
our oceans fortunately though the death
of our good old Sun isn't going to
happen for at least five billion years
so we will all be dead by then but one
thing we do have to worry about which is
a bit shorter term is asteroids it's
understandable if you're not really that
worried about asteroids I mean have you
ever seen an asteroid fall to earth
probably not so what's the big deal but
a good way you can get an idea of how
often asteroid attacks actually happen
is to take a look at the surface of the
Moon do you see all those little holes
there on the moon asteroids they're all
asteroid attacks that look exciting
isn't it also you might have heard about
these giant lizard things that used to
roam the earth called dinosaurs they did
it for about 160 million years so they
were pretty good at living better than
humans as well however it has recently
been accepted by the scientific
community that the most likely reason
for the extinction of the dinosaurs was
an asteroid that could be the human race
as frightening as all of this stuff can
be to think about though I am genuinely
thankful that science has figured it out
because let's face it knowledge of scary
things is going to make us more likely
to survive for scary things although to
my knowledge I'm pretty sure that we
don't have anything in place currently
to stop the asteroids if they do come so
happy Halloween you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool hi and welcome to my light
cluster end screen you want to know this
but I was actually wearing a top hat
there it is for that entire video but
it's impossible to see because the
lighting is so dark but now you know
click on me if you'd like to see
something else don't really know what
yet I haven't decided probably more
science but who knows it's a mystery why
not try out and see love these n screens
don't you